Un saludo para ustedes y un feliz día de
la mujer para todas nuestras
televidentes y la situación es bastante
complicada ayer hablaba el presidente
luiski con la cadena norteamericana
tienen y el policía que se había reunido
con sus militares y que permanecerían
luchando por una ciudad que ellos llaman
estratégica él decía que si perdían
a una nueva ofensiva rusa para tomar
otros lugares estratégicos de Tomás como
la ciudad de kramators
esto contradice algo que había antes
dicho algunas de las organizaciones que
siguen la guerra como el instituto de
estudios de la guerra en Washington que
decía que realmente Rusia no tendría la
capacidad militar para seguir una gran
ofensiva en la medida que las tropas
ucranianas se retiraran totalmente de lo
que sabemos en este momento es que como
decía o por lo menos así lo Argumenta
este jefe paramilitar de las es que
tienen el control del lado este de la
ciudad donde ya tenían bastante
presencia ahora los ucranianos se han
retirado pero se han reforzado no
solamente en el en el centro sino en el
oeste y han venido trayendo refuerzos de
unas tropas bastante importantes y
bastante bien entrenadas como hemos ido
hablando durante los últimos días en
este cubrimiento muchos se preguntan si
las hombres que están perdiendo Rusia
que son básicamente convictos que
pertenecen a estos grupos paramilitares
son tan importantes como los hombres de
alto nivel que está perdiendo Ucrania
dicen que la proporción es de siete
rusos por uno ucraniano pero recordemos
que la proporción de fuerzas entre ambos
ejércitos también es bastante grande
Catalina el secretario general de la ONU
está en kief cuál es el objetivo de Esta
visita precisamente hoy
Esta es la tercera visita Gutiérrez hace
a la capital ucraniana y se ha venido en
esta ocasión hablar otra vez de ese
acuerdo sobre la exportación de los
granos que costó tanto sacar adelante el
año pasado están buscando renovarlos
viene a hablar con Ucrania que también
se ha mostrado optimistas sobre los
lugares de acuerdo pero en este momento
donde las complicaciones
pues hace hasta bastante complicado
recordemos que la exportación del Gran
ucraniano es fundamental para la
alimentación de grandes países en el
mundo especialmente en el África y en
otros países que tienen como dieta
principal el pan